donc par courrier en date du 17 mars
dernier madame la Première ministre a
fait savoir à madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale que le Président
de la République envisage de nommer
Monsieur Lionel Collet aux fonctions de
président du collège de la Haute
Autorité de Santé la hache has je vais y
arriver nous sommes donc réunis ce matin
pour émettre un avis public sur cette
proposition conformément au disposition
de l'article 13 de la Constitution des
lois organiques et ordinaires du 23
juillet 2010 et de l'article 29-1 de
notre règlement notre commission doit
ainsi nommer un rapporteur appartenant à
un groupe d'opposition ou minoritaire
en septembre dernier nous avons donc
désigné nos référents les référents
étant appelés à exercer le moment venu
ses fonctions donc de rapporteur donc le
moment est venu à mon cher collègue
Yannick Neder référant de la Commission
pour la chas qui sera donc notre
rapporteur au préalable je crois utile
donc de préciser comment notre réunion
va se dérouler je vous demanderai
d'abord monsieur colère une dizaine de
minutes de vous présenter et de nous
donner quelques orientations sur la
manière dont vous envisagez les
fonctions auxquelles vous allez être
donc désigner sachant que les
commissaires ont déjà eu communication
en tous les cas de votre curriculum
vitae ensuite je donnerai la parole à
notre rapporteur à Monsieur neuder pour
10 minutes à l'issue desquels vous
disposerez du temps nécessaire pour
répondre après vos réponses le
rapporteur c'est le juge bien sûr
nécessaire pourra vous demander de
préciser ou de compléter donc certains
points après cette nouvelle série donc
de réponse éventuelles je donnerai la
parole aux orateurs des groupes et aux
autres députés pour
deux minutes mes chers collègues nous
conclurons bien sûr par vos réponses à
l'ensemble donc de ces questions une
fois notre audition terminée nous
passerons au vote sur cette proposition
donc de nomination bien sûr or sans la
présence de Monsieur collet il s'agit
d'un scrutin secret pour lequel des
bulletins est une enveloppe vous ont été
donc remis à l'entrée de la salle
je rappelle que l'article 13 de
l'instruction générale du bureau dispose
que les délégations du droit de vote ne
peuvent avoir effet pour un scrutin
secret donc petite précision comme vous
le savez le président de la République
ne peut procéder à une nomination
lorsque l'addition des votes négatifs
dans chaque commission compétente de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat
représente au moins 3/5 des suffrages
exprimés au sein donc de ces deux
commissions j'indique monsieur collet
que vous avez été auditionné en début
donc de matinée par la commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat le
dépouillement concomitant des bulletins
de vote dans les deux assemblées pourra
donc intervenir dès que nous aurons
terminé bien sûr le vote
à cette fin j'habite donc deux collègues
ou plus de la majorité des oppositions à
se faire à se faire connaître afin de se
porter garant de notre vote et de prêter
leur concours en tant que scrutateur
pour ce dépouillement à l'issue de
l'audition y a-t-il donc des personnes
qui souhaitent être sucrés madame
dubrechirat une autre personne
oui très bien monsieur Muller très bien
je vous remercie mes chers collègues et
puis donc sans tarder je vais passer la
parole donc à Monsieur collet
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés j'ai effectivement
l'honneur de me présenter devant vous
puisque le président de la République
propose me propose pour occuper des
fonctions de président de la Haute
Autorité de Santé
madame la Présidente j'avais prévu plus
long mais je vais le faire en 10 minutes
puisque c'est la demande c'est la règle
donc pour résumer mon parcours je suis
conseiller d'état depuis 10 ans ça fera
10 ans cette année mais auparavant
j'étais médecin hospitalier
universitaire à Lyon j'ai occupé j'étais
professeur des universités praticiens
hospitalier durant 21 ans aux Hospices
Civils de Lyon et des chefs de service
d'installis d'audiologie pendant une
douzaine d'années sur le plan
universitaire j'ai créé un laboratoire
de recherche CNRS du MR CNRS que j'ai
dirigé pendant 15 ans et aussi un
groupement de recherche CNRS sur la
prothèse auditive que j'ai dirigé
pendant quatre ans juste un point mes
travaux portaient sur une neurosciences
sensorielle et plus spécifiquement sur
l'audition humaine ce sont des travaux
qui sont à l'Inter des sciences
biologiques quand on étudie la
physiologie du système auditif et des
sciences humaines et sociales dès lors
qu'on étudie la perception auditive
notamment et le travail sur les
prothèses auditives c'était évidemment
un travail sur des dispositifs médicaux
pendant la totalité de ma carrière qui
est un peu moins de 40 ans j'ai pendant
deux années était en cabinet ministériel
un peu plus d'un année comme directeur
de cabinet de la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche Geneviève fiorazo et un peu
moins d'un an comme conseiller spécial
de la ministre des Solidarités et de la
santé Agnès buse alors permettez-moi
d'abord de rendre un hommage à la
présidente sortante de la HS Dominique
Le guludet qui a eu un présidé cette
très grande autorité dans la pire
période que nous ayons connu sanitaire
dans ce pays il doit de soi que je salue
par le même âge l'ensemble des
personnels de la Haute Autorité de santé
pour aller très vite ma vision de
l'institution d'abord
la chaise comme vous le savez elle a une
mission singulière dans le paysage des
organismes publics d'expertise en santé
c'est elle doit expertiser la qualité du
système de santé et elle a été créée à
des fins de régulation ce système de
santé par la qualité par l'efficience
elle a une seconde deuxième singularité
c'est une autorité publique indépendante
et c'est la seule parmi les organismes
publics d'expertise en santé alors il y
a une autorité administrative
indépendante c'est l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire mais les autres sont des
établissements publics des épices voir
un gîtes
elle a une particularité c'est que le
législateur
a fait que ces dispositions sont
codifiées dans le code de la sécurité
sociale et non dans le code de la santé
publique alors que la HS intervient dans
le champ de l'assurance maladie mais
aussi dans le champ de la santé publique
c'est l'histoire puisqu'elle a été créée
par la loi du 13 août 2004 relative à
l'assurance maladie et qu'elle a été
créée pour évaluer l'utilité médicale
des actes des produits de santé des
prestations
prises en charge par l'assurance maladie
et aussi pour promouvoir les bonnes
pratiques professionnelles dans le
système de santé et ce qui est frappant
c'est que la disposition
dans le code de la sécurité sociale qui
définit les missions entre 2004 sa
création et on va dire 2024 l'an
prochain nous fêterons ses 20 ans
nous en serons la 30e version 30
versions de l'article des missions de la
HS en 20 ans et 30 versions non pas par
une modification mais par des ajouts
successifs de mission en 2004 l'émission
elles étaient numérotées de 1 à 5
1er janvier 2024 c'est de 1 à 22 mais il
y a un bis en plus et d'autres missions
qui apparaissent nos numérosté ça cela
traduit l'attente
du législateur l'attente des pouvoirs
publics pour la chas car elle est la
garante de la qualité dans le domaine de
la santé dans le domaine de notre
système de santé et cela explique ces
ajouts successifs d'ailleurs plusieurs
propositions de loi actuelle
confiées également je pense à l'accès
aux soins je pense aussi au Bien
Vieillir confie également des missions à
la HS alors si on fait un tour rapide
des grandes missions qui ont été
ajoutées depuis ce temps-là il y a
renforcement de l'évaluation
médico-économique
il y a eu la commission technique des
vaccinations qui est arrivée à la HS il
l'intégration des missions d'une agence
qui était l'Agence nationale de la
qualité et de l'évaluation des services
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
ce qui fait que la HS développe la
qualité non seulement dans le champ
sanitaire mais aussi dans le champ
social et dans le champ médico-social et
ça c'est la définition de la santé vu
par l'OMS vous le savez bien bien-être
complet il tape bien-être complet mental
physique et social comme on le sait et
puis la chaise c'est beaucoup investi
dans la i santé parce que l'essor de ce
qu'on appelait avant les nouvelles
technologies qui sont technologies qui
continuent à avancer nécessité d'avoir
des avis sur la qualité et sur leur
sécurité donc le travail est un travail
considérable la chasse aujourd'hui elle
rend des avis
en vue de remboursement sur les produits
de santé elle formule des
recommandations recommandations de
bonnes pratiques recommandations
vaccinale et puis elle prend des
décisions notamment certification des
établissements de santé à créditation
des spécialités médicales à risque ou
même la certification en ce qui concerne
la visite médicale ce qu'on appelle la
promotion et la formation donc ça c'est
la vision institutionnelle de la chasse
maintenant
si nous raisonnons à 10-15 ans c'est
bien au-delà du mandat d'un président de
has ou d'un collège où sera la HS bon
elle remplira bien évidemment ses
missions il n'y a pas de discussion sur
la qualité mais on peut raisonnablement
penser que dans l'expertise la place des
usagers et des patients sera encore
renforcés parce qu'ils apportent leur
savoir quel savoir de l'expérience sera
également renforcé la place des experts
dans le domaine des sciences humaines et
sociales parce qu'ils peuvent apporter
des conséquences sur l'impact sur la
société ou encore sur ce qui relève de
l'appropriation comme des
recommandations et dans ces deux cas si
vous m'accordez votre confiance
dès qu'il y aura le prochain
renouvellement ou désignation d'experts
nous commencerons effectivement à
renforcer ces deux types d'experts
usagés patients et expert en sciences
humaines et sociales
d'autre part d'ici 10-15 ans les
recommandations de la HS devront avoir
encore plus d'impact aujourd'hui alors
il y a une commission de l'impact des
recommandations ces recommandations sont
très grandes qualités mais la question
c'est sont-elles mises en œuvre et donc
est-ce que le professionnel de santé on
a connaissance et donc le travail doit
porter sur une simplification de la
présentation des recommandations doit
travailler sur les liens avec les
sociétés savantes tout en sachant que
les sociétés savantes ont des liens
d'intérêt peuvent avoir des conflits
d'intérêts et donc il doit y avoir un
cahier des charges très strict qui a
déjà été élaboré par la chasse et qui
doit s'appliquer elles doivent être dans
enseignées dans le déformation initiales
des différentes professions de santé
mais aussi apparaître après dans le
développement professionnel continu ou
dans la certification périodique des
professionnels de santé
si on raisonne toujours à 10-15 ans le
législateur a souhaité qu'il y a un
rapport annuel
qui vous est présenté de la HAS à vous
et au gouvernement or le législateur
aussi demandé que ce rapport annuel
comporte une analyse prospective avec
des propositions d'amélioration du
système de santé à la fois sur les plans
de la qualité de l'efficience de
l'efficacité
ça c'était la LFSS pour 2018 et il y a
eu chaque année effectivement
un rapport d'analyses prospective
thématique la révolution numérique en
santé cette année c'est l'expertise
publique en situation de crise on
sentait en situation de crise il me
semble que l'esprit du lisateur c'était
aussi avoir au moins une fois dans la
vie d'un collège c'est-à-dire tous les
six ans un autre type de rapport
d'analyse prospective un rapport qui
partait des innovations les plus
significatives et qui essayait
d'expliquer quelles étaient les
modifications que cela pouvait conduire
dans l'organisation du système de santé
et pour faciliter et anticiper les accès
aux soins
et la chaise est très bien placée
puisqu'elle est nourrit des innovations
qu'elle instruit aux médicaments des
médicaments et notamment des dispositifs
médicaux et donc
il me semble logique en résonant à 10-15
ans qu'il y a ce rapport régulier
d'analyse prospective pilotée par la HS
mais qui se ferait en lien avec les
autres agences organismes qui sont liens
avec l'innovation l'agence de
l'innovation en santé cela va de soi la
NSM les organismes de recherche comme
l'Inserm ou le CNRS
si nous continuons à raisonner à 10-15
ans je vais aller assez vite là dessus
il y aura mon avis les conséquences de
la période covid qui seront encore là et
quels sont ces premières conséquences
c'est que la chaise a dû s'adapter à la
nécessité de répondre en urgence pour
des avis des recommandations et non pas
sur le temps long souvent de l'expertise
et donc la chaise a une efficacité
administrative qui sera à mon sens
renforcée encore pour s'adapter aux
différents délais de rendus de ce qui
est demandé je passe sur la place de
l'Europe et l'Internationale nous
pourrons en discuter je voudrais
maintenant aborder la question de la
présidence de la chasse comment est-ce
que je conçois la fonction de président
de la chasse
d'abord c'est une présence exécutive
elle est même doublement exécutive
d'ailleurs une disposition quand qui
présente le collège dans le code de la
sécurité sociale dit le président du
collège de la chasse virgule président
de la Haute Autorité de santé c'est à
dire que le président est à la fois
président de la Haute Autorité de Santé
donc d'une autorité publique
indépendante et il est président du
collège de la chasse et en tant que
président de l'autorité publique
indépendante il répond à la gestation
sur les autorités publiques
indépendantes ça veut dire que les
services sont placés sous son autorité
ça veut dire qu'il nomme le directeur
général et cela veut dire aussi en ce
qui concerne la HAS que c'est lui qui
nomme les présidents des commissions
spécialisées de la chasse
mais il préside aussi le collège de la
chasse il est un des 8 membres de ce
collège je rappelle que les 8 membres
sont nommés par 5 personnalités
différentes
le président de la République nomme le
président de la chasse mais il y a
ensuite une personne nommée par le
président de l'Assemblée nationale une
par le président du Sénat une par le
président du CESU et quatre par le
ministre ça renouvellement par moitié
comme vous le savez tous les trois ans
et bien le rôle du président c'est qu'il
y ait une vision intégrée des travaux de
la chasse c'est à dire que chacun ne
soit pas que dans son domaine mais que
chaque domaine quand on aborde les
médicaments ou les dispositifs médicaux
soient vu tout de suite les conséquences
sur les recommandations les conséquences
sur les certifications ça veut dire
qu'il faut pouvoir aussi prioriser
hiérarchiser et ça c'est le travail
absolument du président et puis comme
cela a été créé par la loi sur
l'assurance maladie faut pas oublier les
enjeux de la régulation et il est
important que le collège est
connaissance des enjeux de la régulation
j'étais co rapporteur des 4 derniers
PLFSS au Conseil d'État je dis bien
cours à porteur parce que nous sommes
par définition vu la longueur du texte
et les délais courts nous sommes
plusieurs à rapporter donc les quatre
derniers j'ai eu cette approche aussi de
la régulation au moins par les textes
depuis quelques années
n'est que le président soit président de
la Haute autorité ou du collège il doit
garantir l'indépendance de la Haute
Autorité de santé parce que vous avez
décidé que c'était une autorité publique
indépendante à caractère scientifique et
assurer l'indépendance je rappelle la
disposition
législative qui dit que les membres des
autorités administratives et publiques
indépendantes ne sollicite ni reçoivent
d'instructions d'aucune autorité c'est
la loi mais ce n'est pas parce qu'ils
sont indépendants qu'il n'y a pas de
dialogue et moi je souhaite
impérativement un dialogue le plus
fluide possible avec d'une manière
naturelle l'ensemble des pouvoirs
publics mais aussi les patients les
usagers les professionnels de santé les
autres agences les organisent de
recherche et des industriels alors j'ai
pratiqué le dialogue avec les
industriels quand j'ai coordonné l'Oxy
le conseil stratégique des industries de
santé de 2016 donc cela me paraît
fondamental mais dire qu'il y a du
dialogue il doit être en toute
indépendance
entre autres ce que j'ai vu au Conseil
d'État c'est que le Conseil d'État c'est
concilier l'in c'est l'intérêt général
le concilier ça veut dire que si
l'intérêt général c'est d'aborder tel
sujet dans tel délai ce n'est pas une
compromission de le faire à condition
que la vie lui soit totalement dépendant
et c'est sur ce modèle là que je
souhaite effectivement présider et
appliquer les règles d'indépendance à la
chasse indépendance et fluidité du
dialogue l'autre aspect c'est que le
président doit être garant de la qualité
de l'expertise scientifique et donc
d'abord des experts il faut qu'il soit
indépendants et l'indépendant c'est
l'absence de conflit d'intérêt et c'est
la transparence des liens d'intérêt et
ce qui relève de la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts je pratique depuis
plusieurs années car je suis de
coordonnateur du collège de déontologie
de l'Assistance publique hôpitaux de
Paris depuis 4 ans je suis également le
référent déontologue du CHU de Bordeaux
et croyez moi le déontologue c'est son
travail au quotidien la question de la
prévention des conflits d'intérêt
l'expertise scientifique c'est aussi
s'assurer de la qualité des experts sur
le plan scientifique
alors j'ai été 9 ans membre du Comité
national de recherche scientifique qui
est le comité qui recrute et évalue les
chercheurs du CNRS donc là je pourrais
mettre en oeuvre effectivement ce que
j'ai appris dans ces années-là sur les
exigences sur les qualités indé
absolument des experts mais je voudrais
terminer madame le Président avec le
dernier point le Président il doit
assurer la bonne administration de la
Haute Autorité de Santé d'abord c'est
sur un plan humain c'est la qualité des
ressources humaines c'est le dialogue
social c'est la qualité des conditions
de travail même si cela ressort plus du
travail du directeur général mais pareil
tout à fait logique et c'est ce que je
ferai si vous m'accordez votre vote
c'est de fixer un rendez-vous dès mon
arrivée avec les représentants du
personnel les représentants du CSE ça me
paraît indispensable au sein de
l'entreprise mais il y a une deuxième
question c'est la question des moyens
aujourd'hui
les ressources viennent pour l'essentiel
d'une ligne du PLFSS qui prévoit la
dotation de la Haute Autorité dotation
qui parvient par l'assurance maladie
c'est de l'ordre de 54 millions d'euros
annuel
les charges de l'Assurance Maladie
l'année dernière sont de l'ordre de 72
millions d'euros 54 millions 72 millions
vous comprenez qu'il en manque à peu
près 18 un peu moins de 20 mais jusque
là c'était possible car jusqu'en 2014 la
HS percevait des taxes et des redevances
des industriels mais qu'elle n'a plus
perçu à partir 2014 a été versé ailleurs
pour des raisons d'indépendance de la
chaise mais l'achat s avait un fond de
roulement suffisamment élevé pour
pouvoir chaque année prélever sur ce
fond de roulement et pour arriver à
l'équilibre mais fonder roulement sera
épuisé à la fin de 2023
ce qui veut dire que vous serez amené à
examiner le plfs 2024 et il paraît
essentiel pour que la HS fasse soit
capable
d'assurer la totalité de ses missions je
rappelle 30 versions d'un article en 20
ans il me paraît indispensable et je me
permets d'insister dessus qu'il y a un
rebasage fondamental de la dotation
justement de la Haute Autorité santé de
près de 20 millions d'euros qui est la
somme qui était prélevée effectivement
sur le fond de roulement annuellement
sinon ce sera vraiment très très
difficile pour la chaise donc j'ai
essayé de résumer madame la Présidente
permettez-moi de m'arrêter ici de
répondre aux questions
merci donc je vais à présent passer la
parole à Yannick nodeur notre rapporteur
pour 10 minutes
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur collet pour pour cette exposé
je voudrais tout d'abord renouveler mes
remerciements à Madame le guldudec pour
la qualité des échanges des travaux
qu'on a pu avoir lorsque j'ai été nommé
référent de la Haute Autorité de Santé
pour l'Assemblée nationale je me réjouis
de pouvoir déjà échanger avec Monsieur
collet et dont la nomination est
envisagée par par l'exécutif et on a pu
mesurer à travers sa présentation de sa
très grande expérience notamment par son
CV avec ses fonctions de PUPH avec des
missions dans le soin dans la recherche
dans l'enseignement en étant été
président d'université et dans le
management des expériences multiples que
je vais d'ailleurs pas tout égrainer
pour pas consommer mon temps de parole
mais qui nous fait toucher du doigt qui
effectivement on va pouvoir travailler
dans de bonnes conditions je vais
rapidement rentrer dans les quatre
éléments sur lequel je voudrais
effectivement porter l'attention de la
Commission et susciter quelques éléments
de réponse même si j'entends bien que
c'est la première audition et que nous
allons je l'espère avoir le temps de
pouvoir peaufiner les choses je voudrais
revenir sur sur les moyens que vous
venez d'ailleurs d'évoquer puisque lors
de l'audition du 4 avril votre votre
prédécesseur avait tenu des propos peu
rassurants en disant en indiquant je
l'acide qui a laissé derrière elle une
HS en déficit de moyens et de ressources
et elle ajoute qu'à l'avenir en l'état
la chasse n'arriverait pas à remplir
toutes ces missions avec les effectifs
et les moyens actuels donc ma question
est assez simple
faites-vous une priorité de ce mandat
sur les moyens et envisagez-vous d'y
palier tant nous savons le rôle
important de cette de cette autorité
ensuite je voudrais revenir en deuxième
point sur une interrogation qui subsiste
de nouveau après l'audition de Madame
lugulidec et j'ai été de nouveau la
saisie par des professionnels de
l'oncologie vous n'êtes pas non plus
sans censé
me connaître le courrier récent des 150
oncologues qui a été rédigé le 17
février dernier qui a été transmis à
l'APL le 5 avril dernier avec notamment
dans les consignataires un ancien
président de la Haute Autorité de santé
qui ces acteurs portent toujours en
regard très triste très très critique
pardon sur la doctrine de la chas en
matière d'évaluation du service médical
rendu le fameux asmr des médicaments
innovants après le rendu d'avis
défavorable pour la fixation du
remboursement pour des médicaments en
oncologie et en hématologie la
Commission de la transparence de la
Haute Autorité de Santé leur attribut le
plus faible niveau d'amélioration du
service médical rendu c'est à dire une
asmr de niveau 5 ce qui entraîne de fait
une impossibilité de prise en charge du
traitement à l'hôpital via la liste en
Suisse c'est donc inghs or ce manque de
données est induit par un excès précoce
quasiment tué dans l'offre nos souvent
pas le temps de pouvoir fournir des
données matures pour évaluer ces
molécules en effet un mois seulement
c'est cool entre les mêmes
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché et
le double avis de la Haute Autorité de
Santé donc ma question est simple est-ce
que vous pensez que l'on peut envisager
une modification de cette doctrine pour
éviter naturellement de deux écueils
importants c'est de le faire comme l'on
fait d'autres pays la France l'Allemagne
l'Italie et ne pas contraindre des
patients de quitter le pays pour avoir
accès à ces molécules et surtout pour ne
pas envoyer non plus un signal négatif
au promoteur de médicaments innovants
qui ferait que finalement la France
n'est pas un pays qui privilégie
l'innovation il me semble que ces
éléments sont
urgents et que l'évolution du cadre
pourrait se faire rapidement le
troisième point sont effectivement et
vous l'avez compris
ses sentiments de trous dans la raquette
sur ces autorisations de mise sur le
marché conditionnelle je pense que
il y a quelques années l'innovation
était moins importante on avait une à
deux molécules par an ce qui permettait
au fil de l'eau de régler le flux et de
pouvoir rapidement trouver la solution
par rapport à la file active de patient
l'innovation et c'est tant mieux se
développe on est maintenant à 5 à 6
molécules par an avec des budgets
conséquents des codes qui sont
finalement relativement faibles parce
qu'on est souvent sur sur des niches
donc là encore comment régler ce
problème de trou dans la raquette pour
ces imêmes conditionnelles enfin le
troisième point
c'est globalement votre volonté et on
l'a bien noté de collaborer alors on l'a
bien entendu avec les experts usagers je
vous remercie effectivement d'évoquer
également les séances humaines et
sociales parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'il ne peut pas avoir de grands sauts
d'innovation technologiques sans des
innovations de sciences humaines et
sociales mais sur les sociétés savantes
je vois que vous ne fermez pas la porte
et que vous ouvrez la collaboration je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
très attendu par l'ensemble des sociétés
savantes en y mettant tous les
garde-fous nécessaires pour justement
privilégier ce que vous avez mis
clairement en évidence qui est
l'indépendance de l'agence tout en
privilégiant le dialogue et
naturellement la régulation qui sont qui
sont nécessaires enfin le dernier point
c'est c'est la covid 19 puisque vous
avez rendu effectivement un avis au mois
de mars recommandant la levée de
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
contre la covid 19 on vient d'en parler
longuement en début de de commission sur
un propos de de PPL je voudrais
simplement dire et redire ce que j'ai
dit ce matin sur le délai de réponse de
la Haute Autorité de Santé par rapport
aux autres instances scientifiques en
Europe c'est que ne pensez-vous pas qui
lutter opportun de concentrer les
efforts de l'autorité sur la seule
vaccination contre la covid-19 qui
occupait globalement l'ensemble des
discussions contenu des critiques
formulées sur ces spécificités et ne
pensez-vous pas que la question
finalement qui ne vous a été posée n'est
pas un petit peu trop complexe que de
d'avoir demandé dans une période qui
n'était pas propice de revoir le champ
vaccinal d'une façon globale puisque
vous avez donc inclus dans vos
discussions le DT Polio l'hépatite B la
grippe naturellement la covid et que le
process de fonctionnement de la Haute
Autorité de Santé et naturellement de
pouvoir faire un certain nombre
d'auditions de faire une revue de la
littérature et surtout d'aboutir à un
consens donc ce que je ne voudrais pas
laisser penser au commissaire de la
commission c'est que en fait les six
mois qui nous ont pénalisés par rapport
à d'autres pays européens par rapport à
la réponse n'est pas tant sur la qualité
et la durée de la réponse mais c'est en
fait la question qui vous a été posée
qui n'était pas la bonne puisqu'on vous
a pas demandé de la question qui on vous
a posé n'était pas la réintégration des
soignants mais le statut vaccinal et je
veux absolument marteler cela parce que
ça laisserait sous-entendre que notre
autre autorité de santé française serait
moins performante serait moins agile
serait moins
pertinente que les autres autorités
scientifiques des autres pays européens
voilà écoutez je vais pas je reprendrai
éventuellement la question mais je pense
qu'on peut en rester là sur les quatre
éléments d'intervention
merci bien monsieur le député bien je
donne la parole tout de suite à Monsieur
collet pour des éléments de réponse
merci madame la Présidente et merci
monsieur le député vous abordez vraiment
plusieurs questions mais je vais y
répondre aussi précisément le possible
HS oui un déficit de moyenne ressources
si il n'y a pas un rebasage alors je
sais qu'il est de bon ton quand on se
présente un poste d'expliquer qu'avec
les moyens on va être capable de faire
les choses je suis désolé mais je vois
pas comment avec un budget qui nécessite
plus de 70 millions 72 millions de
charges et avec une dotation 54 millions
on va y arriver il faut avoir
l'honnêteté de dire ce n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas possible et le
nombre de missions qui considérables qui
est essentiel pour la qualité de nos
systèmes de santé appel effectivement
des moyens sous de forme les moyens
en termes financier donc PLFSS et
j'assiste pour dire que c'est dans le
prochain PLFSS mais aussi au sein du PLF
en terme de plafond d'emploi qui est
actuellement saturé bien évidemment qui
doit être
438 à peu près ou 440 438 ETPT et donc
il est important à mon sens de revoir
tout cela mais ça c'est le poids de
l'histoire je veux dire on l'entend mais
aujourd'hui on est arrivé au bout d'une
histoire avec l'existence de plus de
fondrement et des 30 versions de
l'article de mission comme donc il faut
pas l'oublier et juste et la présidente
le rappelle que sur ces 30 ans il y a eu
une fois une augmentation d'un budget
c'est lorsque l'agence qui s'occupait de
l'évaluation pour simplifier des
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
a vu ses missions intégrer la chas il y
a eu une dotation supplémentaire de 7
millions d'euros pour y faire face mais
depuis il y a eu sur deux années
successives une diminution de un
demi-million et une fois de 2 millions
d'euros sur la dotation de la chasse
donc je veux vraiment vous alerter mon
rôle est d'alerter sur ce point-là alors
maintenant vous abordez monsieur le
député la question des médicaments
innovants avec le cas très particulier
fait très spécifique on a vu en
oncologie
comme citoyen moi je souhaite que chacun
ait l'accès effectivement au traitement
innovant de qualité efficace et bien
évident et comme médecin au moins de
formation tout particulièrement
mais le rôle de la chaise c'est de
garantir la qualité et dans le cas
précis du médicament contre le myélome
je rappelle que il y avait une AMM
conditionnelle qui avait été délivrée je
rappelle que la chaise a dit qu'il y
avait un SMR donc un service médical
rendu important donc qui ouvre le
remboursement mais à classer en asmr 5
donc amélioration du service médical
rendu et non pas 4 et à partir de 4
comme vous l'avez rappelé c'est un
inscription sur la liste en Suisse et la
prise en compte par les établissements
et là on est dans une situation qui est
un classique l'amélioration du service
médical rendu c'est avec un comparateur
quand le comparateur existe on peut dire
bon ça fonctionne mieux ça fonctionne
moins bien et là c'est l'ASMR 5 facile
ce n'est pas meilleur il y a le cas où
il y a pas de comparateur parce qu'il
n'y a pas eu justement d'études
randomisée parce que le produit est
arrivé récemment sur le marché et dans
lequel nous devons et je m'en réjouis la
doctrine de la CT de la Commission de la
transparence a évolué puisque la
dernière doctrine nous devons avoir plus
qu'un simple regard sur les données en
vie réelle tel qu'elles sont fournies
avec ce médicament
et je me réjouis qui est une avancée
déjà des données de la prise en compte
donnée en vie réelle c'est un des
premiers sujets que j'aborderai avec
Pierre Cochin président de la Commission
de la transparence sur l'évolution pour
faire face à cela
j'ai coordonné le 6 de 2016 donc le
conseil stratégique des industries de
santé c'était déjà une question comment
est-ce que vous évaluez l'innovation
comment est-ce que vous prenez en charge
les données en vie réelles qui étaient
soulevées à la chaise donc là c'est
indiscutable la doctrine doit s'adapter
cela étant si on me permettait et la
présente le galludex a toujours rappelé
sur l'accès précoce 80% des demandes
d'accès précoce ont été accordées 80% et
alors qu'il y avait pas forcément de
comparateur
systématiquement et rien qu'en oncologie
c'est environ 90%. donc il y a un cas
très spécifique de ce médicament sur le
mylome qui si je me trompe avec artisel
donc
et qui pose une question mais j'ai
vraiment l'intention de m'en emparer
vous avez évoqué la place des sociétés
savantes
oui je considère qu'on doit démultiplier
les recommandations par des travaux
délégués aux sociétés savantes
labellisés par les sociétés par la SAS
sous réserve qu'elles répondent à un
cahier des charges très strict sur les
liens d'intérêts et les conflits
d'intérêts donc cela doit être
extrêmement précis or ce cahier des
charges a été élaboré et donc moi
j'encourage ce qu'il y a plus de
labellisation mais cela donnera beaucoup
de travail aussi au déontologue de la HS
pour s'assurer effectivement que il y a
une bonne gestion des liens d'intérêts
et des conflits d'intérêts alors ensuite
la question sur le l'obligation
vaccinale sur le covid
vous l'avez rappelé
la chaise répond aux questions pour
lesquelles elle est saisie alors la
saisine portait sur les obligations
vaccinales des professionnels de santé
or à ce jour les obligations vaccinales
il y a deux champs il y a un champ qui
est codifié dans le code de la santé
publique qui précise qu'il y a non pas 4
mais 5 obligations vaccinales je
rappelle diphtérie tétanos polio
je vais revenir sur le terme
d'obligation maximale d'iftérit tétanos
polio hépatite B qui faut pas oublier et
grippe d'ailleurs cet article du code
pour ces 5 pathogies ne parlent pas
d'obligation vaccinales mais
d'obligation d'être immunisée ce qui
veut dire que ce n'est pas exactement la
même chose que l'obligation vaccinale or
je rappelle qu'un décret de 2006 par le
ministre de la Santé de l'époque a
suspendu la vaccination obligatoire des
professionnels de santé contre la grippe
pardon contre la grippe or cela était
suspendu suite à un avis du Haut conseil
de santé publique qui a considéré qu'il
y avait pas de situation pandémique nous
sommes en 2006 et que dès lors
il fallait passer à la forte
recommandation nous sommes en 2006 pour
la grippe et que
si néanmoins une pandémie devait
réapparaître il fallait que l'obligation
à la base ça c'est le code et vous avez
la situation spécifique du covid je
rappelle que là nous sommes dans une
obligation vaccinale qui a été prévue
par une loi de 2021 relative en lien
avec le covid que son article
fondamental pour nous qui est l'article
12 a été modifié par une loi de 2000 22
qui est une loi qui
gérait la fin de la situation peut
d'exception liée au covid et que cet
article de manière très claire puisque
la loi a dit c'était une obligation
maximale dit lorsque peu de choses près
les conditions épidémiques ou les
connaissances médicales et scientifiques
évaluées par la Haute Autorité de santé
le permettront l'obligation sera
suspendu le rôle de la chaise c'était de
répondre là-dessus et la chasse a très
bien répondu ou plutôt à très bien
argumenté en disant il n'y a plus de
pandémie il y a une population qui est
largement admisée a immunisée par des
mois il y a un accès relativement simple
maintenant au vaccin donc nous passons à
la forte recommandation ce qui dans un
autre domaine vous allez me dire que la
grippe n'est pas le covid c'est ce qui
s'était fait en 2006 je veux quand même
rappeler le point sauf que ça signifie
effectivement que le ministre a une
compétence liée pour un décret de
suspension de l'obligation vaccinale
pour que ça devienne une forte
recommandation le délai c'est simplement
que la chaise a répondu à la question
posée qui allait même au-delà de ces six
obligations là-dedans puisque la
question est de mettre à plat y a-t-il
d'autres obligations vaccinales
nécessaires pour le professionnel de
santé et je sais qu'elle travaille
là-dessus et qu'elle devrait rendre si
j'ai bien compris sa copie allaiter à
peu près en juillet voilà donc ça l'est
donc le délai ce n'est pas un délai HS
qui a eu le moment nous avons ouh là je
suis pas nous ou là ça a été saisi et
indiscutablement peut effectivement
discuter de ce que vous dites c'est
pourquoi avoir abordé l'ensemble des
vaccins et pas d'abord uniquement le
covid la question demandée de répondre
sur l'ensemble des vaccins donc voilà je
crois que j'ai répondu madame ne serait
toutes les questions du député très bien
monsieur noder les réponses vous donnent
satisfaction
résidente
parfaitement vous n'avez pas d'autres
questions donc je peux passer à vos
collègues je vous remercie le président
merci bien monsieur le député donc je
passe la parole à Madame Stéphanie ris
pour le groupe Renaissance merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur collet merci de votre propos
introductif de vouloir renforcer la
place des experts
usagers patients merci de vouloir
continuer à garantir l'indépendance et
de le poursuivre dans le dialogue et
merci de vouloir vous l'avez dit
prioriser les sujets qui sera peut-être
une réponse aux négociations financière
que nous aurons peut-être nous avons
pris connaissance des dernières
recommandations de la Haute Autorité
concernant les obligations vaccinales
sur ce point alors que l'on voit que nos
concitoyens nos professionnels de santé
parfois des parlementaires font face à
une période d'interrogations voire de
remise en question de notre rapport à la
science sur ce sujet qu'elle pourrait
être selon vous les travaux à imaginer à
mener pour initier un nouveau chapitre
en matière de politique vaccinale en
France
il y a encore quelques jours nous
portions notre attention sur une
proposition de loi que nous avons porté
avec mes collègues concernant
l'amélioration de l'accès aux soins par
la confiance aux professionnels de santé
plusieurs mesures de ce texte entendent
développer la coopération entre
professionnels de santé en 2008 déjà las
recommandait d'ailleurs d'agir vite sur
ce sujet quels travaux devraient être
menés selon vous pour convaincre les
professionnels qu'on a entendu encore
très craintifs ces dernières semaines
quant à la qualité des soins malgré ses
coopérations et enfin pour conclure
pouvez-vous nous dire par ailleurs
comment la Autorité de santé va répondre
aux enjeux majeurs des évolutions
technologiques de la place de
l'intelligence artificielle on voit que
cela va très vite et notamment dans
l'évolution des métiers de la santé
merci beaucoup merci bien la parole est
à Monsieur Frédéric Falcon pour le
rassemblement national
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur collet
mes chers collègues les recommandations
émises par la Haute Autorité santé
pendant la période covid en durablement
écornée la crédibilité de cette
institution à la confiance que nous
pouvons placer en elle nous l'avons
évoqué un peu plus tôt dans cette
commission le fait que la HAS persiste à
recommander l'obligationale pour les
soignants et personnes suspendus alors
que tous les pays du monde avaient levé
cette interdiction depuis des mois pose
de sérieuses questions quant à
l'indépendance réelle de la Haute
Autorité de santé si on a partialité ça
mit sous tutelle direct du gouvernement
qui rappelons-le nomme ses membres la
science et la santé doivent être
maintenue hors de touchant idéologique
ou politique et oeuvrer pour le bien
commun la chaise comprend 8 commissions
spécialisées chargées d'un souhait les
dossiers portant sur différents champs
de compétences dans la commission de
transparence chargée de l'évaluation des
médicaments dans ce cadre elle émet des
recommandations suite aux saisines dont
elle est l'objet le programme de travail
pour 2023 qui vient d'être publiée à
test d'une charge de travail croissante
que la HS semble avoir des difficultés à
juguler
effectivement les délais d'évaluation ne
cesse de s'allonger ralentissant l'accès
des patients aux médicaments les plus
innovants le délai moyen d'accès en
France et de 527 jours à mener à 220
jours dans le cadre d'une procédure
d'accéder obligatoire contre 120 jours
en Allemagne le directive européenne
fixe pourtant un objectif de délai
d'accès à 180 jours nous en sommes très
loin ce qui a des conséquences notables
pour les patients français si l'on
compare la situation de la France avec
celle de nos voisins européens nous
comprenons que la hache la HAS prend le
chemin d'un monstre administratif 6
symptomatique du déclin français un
frein à l'innovation scientifique
médicale et industriel ma question va
concerner plus particulièrement le rôle
de la chasse sur l'évaluation des
produits de santé allez-vous au cours de
vos six années de mandat tout mettre en
oeuvre pour aider à la diffusion de
l'innovation française dans l'intérêt de
la santé des Français du respect de
notre souveraineté sanitaire je vous
remercie
très bien la parole est à Madame Elise
le boucher pour la France insoumise
nupes merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur Colette chers collègues alors
comme précédemment dit je vais répéter
les propos de Madame le guludet
présidente actuel de la HS lors de son
audition par la commission des affaires
sociales 4 avril dernier non aujourd'hui
je ne laisse pas une maison la HS avec
les moyens qu'il faut à mon successeur
nous avons à la fois des problèmes de
déficit de ressources et des déficits
humains
la HS emploi 425 collaborateurs fait
appel à des experts externes et son
budget annuel est d'environ 63 millions
le déficit de ressources était
prévisible la HS avait un fond de
roulement important puisqu'elle
recueillait elle-même les contributions
des industriels lorsque la HS évaluait
leur dossiers pour des raisons de bonne
gestion financières il a été demandé à
la chaise de résorber ce fond qui est
aujourd'hui épuisé selon l'actuel
Présidente il faudrait redonner ce
budget à la HS de l'ordre de 15 millions
annuels sinon elle n'arrivera pas
poursuivre ses missions à l'identique
alors que ces missions se sont
considérablement élargies en 2012 puis
en 2018 avec la reprise des missions
d'évaluation externe des établissements
médico-sociaux la HS n'a visiblement
plus les moyens d'assurer l'ensemble de
ce prérogative en conservant d'une part
un haut niveau d'expertise et d'autre
part en garantissant l'indépendance de
son expertise
monsieur colley comment vous positionnez
vous vis-à-vis de ce besoin vital de
financement considérez-vous le budget
annuel de la chaise insuffisant quelle
marge de négociation détenez-vous en vue
d'augmenter l'association la dotation à
louer à la HAS et en vue du PLFSS a
combien s'immez-vous les besoins
budgétaires de l'institution merci
merci bien la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane Viry pour les républicains
oui merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
effectivement il y a quelques jours nous
avions interrogé la directrice actuelle
et la question des moyens de
l'institution avait été posé
moi ce qui ce qui me préoccupe ce qui ne
préoccupe à ce stade c'est la légitimité
la crédibilité la confiance en la Haute
Autorité de son thé nous y tenons parce
qu'on a besoin de croire en relation on
a besoin de croire l'indépendance de
votre institution on a besoin que vous
continuez vous et vos équipes à évaluer
à viser recommandé mais nous voulons
avoir deux certitudes la première
certitude c'est qu'effectivement vous
avez l'indépendance pour le faire et que
vous ne puissiez pas être ce n'est pas
un préjugé ni un procès d'attention vous
ne puissiez pas être vous et vos
collaborateurs et vos équipes attachées
peut-être à des doctrines médicales qui
pourraient être peut-être remise en
question dans l'intérêt des passions
dans l'intérêt d'une nouvelle
organisation de santé on sait que vous
avez évalué des médicaments vraiment des
dispositifs médicaux des actes médicaux
et on nous avons un certain nombre
d'interrogations sur la reconnaissance
de certaines ALD ou peut-être à tort
nous pouvons avoir
un regard assez dubitatif sur
l'inertie ou le temps pris pour
reconnaître un certain nombre de
pathologies comme des ALD donc la
question elle est sur cette indépendance
intellectuelle de la Haute Autorité de
Santé pour nous permettre d'avoir une
expertise la plus puissante la plus
juste qui redonne de la crédibilité à la
science nous croyons nous dans notre
groupe à la science nous considérons
qu'elle est un élément de légitimité de
crédibilité de puissance d'un pays nous
voyons bien qu'elle a été malmenée par
certaines prises de paroles et par une
période compliquée celle du celle du
covid 19 nous considérons effectivement
que dans les six années à venir la Haute
Autorité de santé doit retrouver une
véritable légitimité ça passera je l'ai
dit par des moyens et sur ça nous
attendons des actes forts de votre part
par une indépendance confirmée et par
une volonté coûte que coûte d'aller de
l'avant
merci bien madame Sandrine Josso pour le
groupe démocrate modem et indépendant
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
collège cher collègue dans le cadre de
votre nomination à la présidence du
collège de la HAS j'aurai deux questions
à vous poser
quels sont les orientations que vous
souhaitez donner à la prévention en
santé environnementale au sein de la HS
je travaille actuellement sur
l'exposition des femmes enceintes à
certains produits toxiques et aux
perturbateurs endocriniens les stalates
notamment ont une part de responsabilité
importante dans la prématurité
souhaitez-vous vous saisir de ces sujets
ça c'est mon premier point le second
concerne la proposition de loi portant
des mesures pour bâtir une société du
Bien vieillir en France actuellement à
l'étude à l'Assemblée nationale la
progression de l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé est un indicateur important
pour suivre l'efficacité des politiques
de prévention et d'accès à la santé
nous savons qu'il existe des écarts
importants en fonction des territoires
mais aussi en fonction des niveaux de
vie
quels sont les orientations que vous
souhaitez proposer en la matière pour
améliorer l'espérance de vie de nos
concitoyens mieux prévenir les maladies
liées à l'âge et à la perte d'autonomie
notamment dans les déserts médicaux je
vous remercie
merci bien la parole est à Monsieur Joël
harbiranier pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté dupesse oui merci madame la
Présidente chers collègues monsieur
collet alors que votre nomination comme
président de la Haute Autorité de Santé
est envisagée par le Président de la
République les députés socialistes
apparentés souhaiteraient connaître
votre position sur la permanence des
soins comme vous le savez la situation
notre système de santé de plus en plus
critique que l'on soit en périphérie des
métropoles dans les territoires ruraux
un outre-mer nos concitoyens ont de plus
en plus de difficultés à se faire
soigner les déserts médicaux sont une
réalité quotidienne pour des millions de
Français et certains renoncent à se
soigner quand d'autres doivent attendre
plusieurs mois pour accéder à certains
sites spécialistes cette situation ne
pouvant plus durer les Français ont
besoin de médecins généralistes et
spécialistes alors à défaut de pouvoir
mobiliser sur le court terme
suffisamment de professionnels de santé
pour répondre à l'urgence la permanence
des soins est une nécessité pour les
territoires soudés dans les de vie la
question ne se pose pas car l'hôpital et
les secteurs de permanence et soins plus
petits permettent à chaque citoyen de se
soigner deux jours comme de nuit à
proximité de son domicile mais à la
campagne l'hôpital le plus proche se
trouve parfois plus d'une heure de
trajet concernant les médecins libéraux
leur raréfaction conduit nécessairesment
affaiblir le dispositif de permanence
des soins les médecins même libéraux ont
des devoirs envers leur patient certains
se démènent pour garantir une offre de
soins de qualité partout sur le
territoire et je veux ici les remercier
pour cet engagement cependant il
m'apparaît nécessaire de rampe forcer
cette permanence des soins dans les
territoires les moins bien dotés à
médecins afin de garantir à chaque
Français un accès aux soins à tout
moment ou qu'il habite sur notre
territoire alors votre parcours
professionnel atteste de votre
engagement au service de notre pays et
des Français aussi je veux profiter de
cette audition pour vous interroger à ce
propos pensez-vous donc qui serait
possible afin de réduire l'écart entre
les recommandations et la réalité
serait-il possible d'améliorer le
dispositif de permanence des soins par
exemple en renforçant le maillage
territorial et en redéfinissant les
secteurs de permanence des soins je vous
remercie
si bien Monsieur Paul Christophe pour le
groupe horizon et apparenté merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur collet mes chers
collègues je souhaite revenir sur la
réforme de l'accès précoce entrée en
application le premier juillet 2021
rappelons-le elle visait à simplifié et
harmoniser les différents dispositifs
d'accès dérogatoires le nouveau
dispositif d'accès précoce permet aux
patients atteint d'une pathologie grave
et en impasse thérapeutique de
bénéficier à titre exceptionnel et
temporaire de certains médicaments
susceptibles d'être innovants près d'un
an et demi après son lancement la HS un
bilan positif vous l'avez rappelé 177
dossiers ont été déposés par les
laboratoires auprès de la Commission de
la transparence 80% d'entre eux ont été
acceptés donc 90% en ontologie cette
réforme de l'accès précoce repose sur le
recueil de données en vie réelle l'enjeu
donc de cet accès dérogatoire est en
effet de déterminer si le traitement
parvient à confirmer les preuves de son
efficacité c'est pourquoi l'autorisation
s'accompagne de la mise en place d'un
protocole d'utilisation thérapeutique et
de recueil de données
le laboratoire est responsable du
recueil des données et de son
financement mais ce sont les
établissements de santé et leurs
professionnels de santé qui doivent les
collecter les transmettre au laboratoire
en pratique nous constatons cependant
une difficulté pour les laboratoires
d'afficher à taux de compétits des
protocoles les professionnels de santé
ont tout simplement pas le temps
nécessaire pour remplir les datas en
outre nous nous interrogeons encore sur
la position officielle le has quant à la
réutilisation des données collectées
dans le cadre de ces accès précoce aussi
mes questions sont les suivantes
monsieur collet ces données dit de vraie
vie permettent-elles réellement de
nourrir l'évaluation de droit commun
faite par la Commission de la
transparence de la chasse notamment pour
les accès précoce préautorisation de
mise sur le marché dites prêt à MM
comment las peut-elle accompagner les
produits en accès précoce vers
l'évaluation de droit commun en veillant
à garantir une cohérence dans
l'évaluation la HS sont les mots de
Madame güder conditionné la semaine
dernière par notre commission fait face
vous l'avez rappelé à des déficits de
ressources notamment humaines quel est
votre regard sur la situation au-delà
financier quelle perspective
envisagez-vous
très bien la parole est à
Marie-Charlotte Garin pour le groupe
écologiste nupes merci madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur collé pour ces
premiers propos j'ai plusieurs questions
en premier lieu la hass a récemment
récupéré une fonction de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
des produits de santé qui est celle
d'attribuer des autorisations d'accès
précoce pour des médicaments innovants
est-ce qu'un premier bilan sur ce
point-là existe déjà la présidente
actuelle de la HS a alerté sur le fait
que l'agence est sous dotée ça a été
rappelé par un certain nombre de mes
collègues et qu'elle manque de personnel
pour remplir ses missions dans ce
contexte là vous avez déjà commencé à
l'aborder mais quelle perspective
voyez-vous pour l'agence dans de telles
circonstances et comment assurer la
pérennité et le maintien de la qualité
de ses travaux
la récente recommandation de la HS de ne
plus obliger les professionnels de santé
à être vaccinés contre la covid et
autres pathogènes a mis en lumière les
différences d'avis qui peut exister
parfois entre experts et acteurs
concernés notamment du côté de
l'autorité scientifique de la HAS du
coup mes questions c'est comment est-ce
que on peut concilier les avis distants
entre les différents acteurs donc quand
c'est l'Académie de médecine les
syndicats de practiciens et les
associations de patients et est-ce que
ces avis qui sont soumis à consultation
avant leur publication dans ce cas
qu'est-ce qui ressort de la consultation
et comment est-ce que c'est
consultations sont prises en compte
enfin j'aimerais aborder la question de
la santé des femmes plusieurs
dispositifs médicaux sont recommandés
aux femmes pour leurs besoins de santé
spécifique c'est le cas par exemple des
bandelettes sous-urétrales ou encore des
implants de stérilisation définitive il
y a d'autres dispositifs qui sont
couramment utilisés par les femmes
telles que les protections hygiéniques
ces dispositifs n'ont pas seulement en
commun d'être utilisés en majorité par
les femmes ils ont aussi en commun de
comporter des matériaux aux produits
chimiques nocifs pour le corps humain à
ce jour les fabricants ne sont pas tenus
d'indiquer la composition de ces
différents dispositifs au détriment de
la santé des femmes quel est votre
position sur l'interdiction des produits
chimiques et matériaux nocifs dans les
dispositifs médicaux gynécologiques et
autrement quelle est votre position sur
l'obligation de transparence sur la
composition des dispositifs médicaux
gynécologiques pour les fabricants je
vous remercie très bien Monsieur Pierre
dareville pour le groupe
gauche-démocrate et républicaine
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
collé je voudrais d'abord vous remercier
pour le langage très offensif que vous
avez tenu à l'égard des besoins qui sont
ceux de la Haute Autorité de Santé pour
faire face à ces à ces missions et
j'espère que tout ça pourra être entendu
mais effectivement même si vous n'êtes
pas la seule agence dans ce cas c'est
une réalité à laquelle nous devons faire
face et donc c'est pour moi un point
extrêmement positif que vous soyez venu
ici nous le dire de cette façon là
peut-être question complémentaire sur le
plafond d'équivalent temps plein auquel
vous êtes assujettis est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire quelques mots je
voudrais souligner les engagements que
vous avez commencé à prendre sur le
Conseil d'engagement des usagers
justement avec le Conseil d'engagement
des usagers et insister peut-être vous
interroger sur la nécessité de faire
progresser la culture sanitaire dans
notre pays comment est-ce que vous
envisagez peut-être les choses et le
rôle de votre institution en la matière
le cylindre en étain et le fait de
favoriser la démocratie sanitaire
troisième élément
concernant les transferts de tâches
entre professionnels de santé est-ce que
vous avez
des avis sur ces questions-là nous
sommes souvent interrogés parfois au fil
de l'eau est-ce que il serait pas
nécessaire d'avoir une vision d'ensemble
sur ces enjeux est-ce que par exemple
vous-même avez une réflexion sur sur ces
questions là
quatrième question concernant les
logiques de protocolisation est-ce que
vous êtes en recherche d'un certain
équilibre parce que il y a parfois un
certain professionnel qui trouve qu'il y
a justement trop de d'injonctions qui
leur sont faites et en même temps il y a
besoin effectivement sans doute d'avoir
des recommandations comment vous voyez
les choses de ce point de vue là et
dernière question comment vis-à-vis vous
pardon de lutter contre la
marchandisation de la santé et les
délocalisations et je rebondirai sur ce
que vient de dire ma collègue
Marie-Charlotte Garin sur les
dispositifs médicaux qui sont un des
lieux privilégiés de la marchandisation
de la santé comment faire
très bien donc monsieur le monsieur
collet si vous le me permettez j'ai cinq
petites questions comme ça vous
répondrez de manière globale à
l'ensemble des questions Monsieur Didier
Martin
merci même la présidente monsieur le
professeur je serai le quatrième de
notre commisho à vous interpeller sur
les innovations thérapeutiques en
particulier pour les patients atteints
de cancer réfractaires après plusieurs
lignes de traitement je me ferai le
porte-parole de l'Association française
des malades du myélome multiple avec des
cas donc sans ressources thérapeutiques
à part une adaptation des chimio de
première ligne avec quelques médicaments
supplémentaires certains d'entre eux
dans un essai thérapeutique ont
bénéficié de cette innovation qui
consiste effectivement à modifier
génétiquement certaines cellules pour
les rendre tueuses du cancer et il
semblerait que les résultats soient
encourageants 60% des patients traités
par cette technique serait deux ans
après 10 signe de maladie et sans
toxicité à long terme 97% aurait une
réponse extrêmement rapide avec une très
bonne qualité de vie reprise des
activités sportives et du travail c'est
des chiffres que je cite au conditionnel
et que je vous rapporte sans les avoir
vérifiés moi-même néanmoins se pose la
question pour ces patients-là et vous
l'avez dit très sincèrement du rôle de
la Commission de transparence de
doctrine peut-être à faire évoluer au
moment de prendre vos fonctions où vous
nous le dites est-ce que vous pouvez
vous engager vis-à-vis de tous ces
patients sont pas très nombreux
peut-être une soixantaine le traitement
est très coûteux aussi il faut bien le
dire 300 340000 euros ce qui fait
d'ailleurs pour les 60 patients en
attente environ les 20 millions d'euros
vous nous avez sollicité pour le
prochain budget donc c'est pas tout à
fait inaccessible au budget de la France
et de l'assurance maladie pouvez-vous
nous répondre sur ce point je vous
remercie
très bien Madame frontaberriti
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur collet pour votre présentation
mes chers collègues bien que les
stratégies de vaccination soient encore
au cœur de l'actualité j'aimerais avoir
abordé avec vous plus précisément l'une
des trois missions de la Haute Autorité
de santé qui consiste à recommander les
bonnes pratiques professionnelles en
effet la bord chaque année une
cinquantaine de recommandations qui
s'adressent directement aux
professionnels du secteur sanitaire
social et médico-social les sujets sont
très variés sujets techniques sociétaux
sujets de pratiques hospitalière ou de
pratiques libérales sujets du secteur
social médico-social etc dans son projet
stratégique donc 2019-2024 la hase s'est
fixée l'objectif d'améliorer l'impact de
ces productions destinées aux
professionnels des champs sanitaires
sociales et médico-sociales pour cela il
a été mené des travaux entre septembre
2019 et avril 2023 qui ont abouti
l'élaboration d'un programme d'action
transversale et pluriannuelle qui a été
annoncé ces derniers jours ma question
est donc la suivante dans le cadre de
votre futur fonction si vous êtes élu
comment accompagnerez-vous ce programme
d'amélioration de l'impact des
recommandations de la hase et comme il
me reste quelques secondes j'aimerais
simplement vous remercier pour nous
avoir présenté très clairement je trouve
votre vision d'avoir parlé de
simplification parce que c'est vraiment
je trouve quelque chose d'important pour
tous merci d'avance pour votre réponse
très bien merci Monsieur Thibaut Bazin
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
collet vous êtes auditionné par notre
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée nationale puisque votre
nomination est envisagée par le
Président de la République en fonction
de président du collège de la Haute
Autorité de Santé je ne reviendrai pas
moi non plus sur votre parcours et vos
références qui ont été rappelés par mon
collègue Yannick Noah j'ai plusieurs
questions la Haute Autorité de Santé
nouvelle mission comme vous les
mentionné dans vos propos introductifs
les défis devant nous sont réels avec
l'émergence de nouveaux risques
sanitaires l'essor de l'intelligence
artificielle les progrès techniques et
thérapeutiques les relevés est une
nécessité pour garantir la confiance
dans notre système de santé vous nous
avez alerté sur le besoin d'augmenter
vos moyens humains et budgétaires pour
répondre aux missions confiées vous avez
également expliqué qu'il faut
hiérarchiser et prioriser très
concrètement si vos moyens humains et
budgétaires n'évoluent pas suffisamment
pour répondre à vos missions quels
seront vos premières priorités vous avez
évoqué à plusieurs reprises la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts
l'expertise scientifique peut être rare
dans certains domaines pointus ceux
d'autant plus si on veut encore des
experts praticiens n'y a-t-il pas des
limites à éviter toute expérience des
intérêts en particulier en matière
d'innovation pour les maladies rares
forts en matière de déontologie quelles
évolutions envisagez-vous concernant les
recommandations de la Haute Autorité de
Santé vous avez mis en exacte le besoin
d'améliorer leur diffusion auprès des
professionnels de santé très
concrètement comment souhaitez-vous
procéder de manière directe ou par des
intermédiaires plutôt par de
l'information descendante ou de la
formation participative quelle méthode
spécifique souhaitez-vous privilégier en
termes de fonctionnement collaboratif
avec le procès de ville qui dit autorité
d'irresponsabilités dans une société où
l'immédiateté prime de plus en plus dans
une société où tout temps à se
judiciariser dans quelle mesure les
risques juridiques encourus peuvent
influencer les actions de la Haute
Autorité de Santé voir l'inaction enfin
le fait dénommé par le Président de la
République peut-elle à me nuire
l'effectivité de l'indépendance de votre
fonction si vous êtes infilé nommé à
l'issue du processus engagé les
décisions du Conseil de défense
doivent-elles respecter les
recommandations de la Haute Autorité de
santé
très bien Monsieur Eric à lozet merci
madame la Présidente merci Monsieur
collet pour votre présentation j'ai
trois questions à vous poser dans un
contexte marqué par une montée de la
défiance dans le pignon public à l'égard
des autorités qu'elle soit politique ou
scientifique un phénomène qui s'est
d'ailleurs accéléré avec la crise
sanitaire du covid à vaccination du
covid avec les multiples controverses
habituellement plutôt confinés dans dans
le milieu des experts des milieux
scientifiques et qui sont retrouvés dans
le débat public au point que on faisait
des sondages pour savoir si nos
concitoyens considéraient que la
chloroquine était efficace ou pas
efficace on est arrivé à vraiment à
n'importe quoi pardon pour cette
expression pourriez-vous nous indiquer
par quels moyens has entend lutter
contre cette défiance et ainsi mieux
faire connaître ses avis deuxième
question
la chasse rappelle sur ce site internet
qu'il existe une diversité de modalités
de participation c'est un point sur
lequel vous avez insisté d'ailleurs pour
ces travaux cependant le 29 mars dernier
veille de la publication par la HS de
ces travaux relatifs aux obligations et
recommandations vaccinales des
professions de santé la directrice du
pôle ressources humaines de la FAF
expliquait que la Fédération n'avait pas
été consultée
pourriez-vous nous éclairer sur les
modalités précisément de consultation
nous préciser leur nature leur évolution
et puis troisième et dernière question
qui a un peu redondante d'ailleurs avec
celle-ci plus généralement quel bidon
peut-on tirer et quelle perspective
peut-on envisager pour la démocratie en
santé sur le point sur lequel vous avez
assisté effectivement plus précisément
quels sont les grandes orientations que
vous envisagez pour mieux associer les
acteurs de santé et les usagers aux
travaux de la HS je vous remercie très
bien dernière intervention madame Nicole
dubrechira merci madame la Présidente
merci Monsieur d'abord félicitations
pour votre parcours riche et variés et
pour la synthèse dans la présentation
que vous nous avez faite d'un bilan déjà
sérié et d'un certain nombre de
perspectives que vous avez évoqué dans
le cadre des missions de la chas avec
des évolutions nécessaires et une
demande de budget supplémentaire dans
une période contrainte est-ce que il est
pas aussi envisagé de prior utiliser les
avis peut-être plutôt que de vouloir les
multiplier ou de répondre à un nombre de
demandes d'une part d'autre part de
simplifier les recommandations
effectivement vous nous avez dit qu'il y
avait eu 50 recommandations
l'année passée on sait que elles sont
très intéressantes et
construite de manière positive seulement
on sait aussi que il y a peu de
sollicitations de ces recommandations
par les professionnels de santé donc
quelle est la politique que vous voulez
développer en matière de communication
sur des recommandations peut-être aussi
plus sérieux et la troisième chose par
rapport au processus de certification
des établissements je fais partie des
soignants qui ont beaucoup participé à
ces assez certifications est-ce que là
aussi on pourrait envisager une
simplification de la procédure pour être
plus pertinent plus performant et plus
avec des éléments qu'on réévalue de la
même manière plutôt que de modifier les
certifications à des périodes
reconduites alors que on n'a pas de
moyens comparatifs donc est-ce que c'est
pas des éléments de simplification dans
tous les domaines qui pourraient
permettre aussi une imitation du budget
de fonctionnement je vous remercie bien
et bien écoutez monsieur collet vous
avez la parole pour voilà pour des
éléments de réponse assez très nombreux
question non nombreuses et souvent
difficile de combien de temps est-ce que
je dispose madame la Présidente
bien et bien je vais donc répondre
ce qui colle bien avec les questions sur
l'indépendance que vous êtes en train de
me soulever bien alors bon
l'indépendance je voudrais partir
d'indépendance puisque plusieurs d'entre
vous s'interrogent est-ce que si on est
nommé par le Président de la République
on peut être indépendant et d'une autre
manière quels sont les indépendants
l'indépendance par rapport à des
tutelles l'autorité peut les prendre n'a
pas de tutelle je le rappelle quand même
c'est ce que vous avez décidé le
législateur en décidant que c'était une
autorité publique indépendante alors moi
je peux simplement vous dire que je vous
garantis que je garantirai
l'indépendance de la chaise et puis je
demande simplement de regarder mon
parcours j'ai présidé une université et
j'ai présidé la Conférence des
présidents d'université je connais peu
d'instances qui revendiquent plus leur
indépendance que ce milieu éruptif qui
est mieux l'université et donc je les ai
assuré pendant un certain nombre
d'années j'ai été pendant 10 ans
conseiller d'État
conseil d'étages parce que personne
doute quand même de son dépense j'espère
que personne n'en doute ce qui veut dire
que j'ai consacré à peu près plus de 15
ans de ma vie à être dans des structures
qui non seulement était indépendante se
revendiquer indépendante se battait pour
l'indépendance et pour tout dire c'est
aussi une des raisons pour laquelle
j'étais très intéressé par le poste de
président de la Haute Autorité de Santé
et je peux simplement regarder mon
parcours vous dire je vous garantis
qu'il y aura l'indépendance mais je dis
garantis également qu'il y aura du
dialogue j'insiste beaucoup sur ces deux
aspects je veux dire l'indépendance
n'est pas antinomique du dialogue il n'y
a pas une compromission parce qu'on
dialogue mais les avis doivent ils
doivent demeurer absolument indépendants
alors l'indépendance elle est
fondamentale pour la confiance de toute
façon et puisque certains d'entre vous
ont une personne disait que la confiance
avait été écornée
très bien ça c'est je l'entends vous
savez dès qu'il y a le mot autorité dans
notre pays il y a une tendance à
s'opposer à ce qu'elle peut dire on peut
discuter les personnes qui en sont
membres ou les avis qu'elle va abonnés à
rendre je le sais moi ce qui me porte
c'est que ces avis soient de qualité et
qu'ils soient préparés en toute
indépendance donc voilà voilà sur ce
point-là ce que je tenais à dire ensuite
on va rentrer dans une autre question
très générale qui est celle des liens
d'intérêt des conflits d'intérêts il y a
plusieurs aspects dans la question le
premier aspect c'est que la S et les
industriels le disent et quand même très
très stricte sur les liens d'intérêt et
sur le fait d'écarter des experts qui
justement ont des conflits d'intérêt
qu'on soit que l'industriel n'est pas
forcément envie que l'expert avec lequel
que la personne avec laquelle il
travaille ne soit pas un expert c'est un
expert et je rappelais ce matin dans une
autre chambre que le lorsque je
coordonnais l'oxyde 2016 j'ai le
souvenir d'un industriel me disant vous
savez
un expert qui a pas de dire d'intérêt ne
présente pas d'intérêt donc c'est un
véritablement la vision de l'industriel
sauf qu'à ce moment-là 2016 je m'étais
retourné par la HS de l'époque j'ai ce
que vous avez des problèmes pour trouver
des experts on dit pas du tout et il
faut pas oublier que même si rien
n'empêche la chaise
d'auditionner d'écouter des
spécialistes on va dire ayant un conflit
d'intérêt mais ce doit être transparent
il ne doivent pas participer à la
décision à aucun moment ils sont
simplement auditionnés donc cela est
totalement possible à partir du moment
où c'est totalement transparent et que
il ne participe pas la décision donc les
informations qui sont leur possession on
doit absolument les pouvoirs les avoir
donc là nous sommes dans les questions
troisième type de question générale si
je veux faire une synthèse plusieurs
d'entre vous m'ont interrogé notamment
sur des situations en lien avec la santé
des femmes
que ce soit sur des risques sur la
question santé environnementale sur la
question de produits toxiques je
rappelle que
la HS répond aux saisines réponse au
saisines et elle peut aussi s'auto
saisir mais la réponse estime et sur les
recommandations c'est demande sont très
nombreuses il faut aussi les prioriser
ce sont des questions dont je ne
discuterai pas qui sont majeurs je
rappelle néanmoins que la HS n'est pas
lancés par exemple qui va s'occuper
effectivement de sécurité
environnementale je veux dire qu'on
n'est pas la NSM non plus je veux dire
ces aspects de néanmoins tout ce qui
relève de recommandations de bonnes
pratiques professionnelles je parle
vraiment de la qualité de la pertinence
c'est le travail de la chaise et à ce
moment-là elle doit également informer
elle aussi de ces situations mais
l'enjeu c'est savoir la priorité parce
que d'autres ont utilisé dans un autre
sens que l'on met non pas à la question
qui me paraît majeure mais dans
l'ensemble du travail qu'on peut
réaliser avec les moyens dont on dispose
je suis désolé de le dire
pas insister mais il y a effectivement
une question dans ce domaine là qui sera
majeur alors parmi les plusieurs
questions que vous avez soulevé madame
la députerie vous avez posé plusieurs
questions
notamment sur
l'accès aux soins sur la qualité des
soins sur les obligations vaccinales
alors
vous le savez parce que la présidente le
gullet vous l'avez dit sur le la
dernière saisine qui avait eu de la HAS
sur les obligations vaccinales des
professionnels de santé il y avait une
saisine parallèle du CCN du Comité
consultatif national d'éthique donc sont
des aspects qui n'ont pas été traités
l'un d'entre vous l'une d'entre vous
faisait allusion
à des réactions suite à cet avis de la
chasse sur les obligations vaccinales je
rappelle que je ne suis pas membre de la
chasse à ce jour mais je me dois d'être
à la fois en situation de prendre la
responsabilité y compris de ce que la
chaise avait dit avant il y a notamment
un avis de l'Académie de médecine donc
vous avez fait allusion qui était pas un
avis contre la ville de HS qui était un
avis qui consiste à dire et c'était le
titre de la vie me semble-t-il c'est la
vaccination un devoir pour les soignants
or l'Académie de médecine s'est prononcé
sur cette question là qui pourra
peut-être être vu par le CCN mais ce
n'était pas la question du tout de la
chasse la question de la HAS c'est
actuellement en raison de l'évolution de
l'épidémie des connaissances est-ce que
l'obligation vaccinale est fondée ou non
et s'était demandé pour le covid comme
pour les autres et d'ailleurs vous savez
que pour le DTP hormis pour Mayotte et
de conseils de passer une forte
recommandation et de matière strictement
la vaccination contre hépatite B comme
obligation partout donc on en est là
mais c'est vraiment une analyse
scientifique telle qu'elle a été
réalisée l'Académie de médecine s'est
mise sur son rôle totalement et qui est
un tout autre mission fonction que celle
de la de la Haute Autorité de Santé donc
voilà les deux trois points par rapport
à cela sur les si on permettait que je
vous m'avez interrogé monsieur le député
d'arriville sur les transferts de tâches
alors je voudrais répondre sur deux
niveaux si vous me permettez
le candidat à la présidence de la chasse
donc et moi-même à titre personnel
d'abord je trouve que le transfert de
tâches n'est pas un terme approprié je
préfère la notion de compétences
partagées car derrière le mot transfert
de tâches ça laisse sous-entendre qu'on
va retirer des tâches à quelqu'un pour
les donner à une autre personne moi je
préfère qu'on dise qu'on partage les
compétences entre les acteurs
je suis un adepte des compétences
partagées à titre personnel avec une
réserve c'est la garantie de la qualité
de la réalisation de l'acte là dedans et
vous savez il y a eu un précédent qui
était la vaccination contre la grippe
lorsque les infirmiers ont été autorisés
avec les nations contre la grippe la loi
un décret il n'était pas autorisé à la
primo vaccination la première
vaccination devait être réalisée par un
médecin et il a fallu une dizaine
d'années pour qu'il y ait une saisine de
la chasse qui a répondu sur le plan de
la revue de littérature il n'y avait pas
plus d'accidents sur la primo
vaccination que ces autres vaccinations
dès lors que elle était réalisée par un
infirmier et non pas par un médecin et
qui a conduit à ce qu'effectivement
actuellement les infirmiers ont la
possibilité d'avoir prévu par par décret
je dirais même légal de pratiquer cette
primo vaccination on est dans une
compétence partagée car le médecin peut
le faire l'infirmier d'autres peuvent
également vacciner mais c'est un autre
débat donc je prends la casquette HS qui
veut dire dès lors qu'on garantit la
qualité
que les critères sont remplis il y avait
eu je crois en 2015 un rapport ou un
avis je ne sais plus de la chaise sur la
délégation de tâches comme on l'appelait
et qui définissait effectivement les
situations de critères je pense que la
chaise doit se prononcer pour préciser
les critères de qualité et considérés
que voilà ce qu'il est possible ou non
que soit réalisé en l'occurrence par un
non médecin je rappelle quand même que
sur la vaccination beaucoup de
professions peut maintenant vacciner les
sages-femmes peuvent vacciner au-delà de
l'entourage du nouveau-né je dirais et
d'autres professions donc la voilà une
position un peu plus personnelle que je
voulais vous que je voulais partager
avec vous alors une question qui revient
et je l'entends parfaitement c'est la
question des innovations je l'ai abordé
tout à l'heure la question du médicament
contre le mylome de l'avons déjà abordé
avec Monsieur le Député notaire
je le redis je suis
très sensible
soucieux de ce qui pourrait mettre en
hauteur des produits de santé efficaces
pour nos concitoyens
mais vous l'avez rappelé il y a un
risque
je rappelle qu'il y a un risque et je
suis également très soucieux d'éviter de
laisser croire qu'un produit de qualité
s'il ne l'est pas sauf que là nous
sommes dans des domaines où nous sommes
dans des domaines où il y a des parts
d'incertitude et dès qu'il s'agit de
l'accès précoce il y a une prise de
risque en fonction des données de
l'incertitude alors la gestion du risque
gestion de la certitude n'était pas dans
la tradition des agences jusque là et là
elle arrive puisque nous sommes sur des
présomptions d'innovation et des
présomptions également de d'apport du
produit et donc on doit être sur ces
deux aspects je veux dire évidemment le
patient peut être dans une logique de
dire moi je veux avoir accès je voudrais
pouvoir accès à ce produit parce qu'on
me dit qu'elle est efficace et la HAS
doit dire sommes-nous certains qu'il est
véritablement efficace quelle est notre
prise de risque et c'est là où il y a
tout un équilibre cela étant
donc ça c'est la doctrine je sais que
pour beaucoup ça ne va pas assez loin et
je vous le dis je vous le redis ça fait
partie des premiers sujets que
j'aborderai avec le président de la de
la CT alors
je crois que j'ai alors j'ai pas répondu
à tout aux questions mais j'essayais de
regrouper un ensemble de questions par
donnez-moi de reprendre mes notes pour
que je m'assure
l'innovation je crois vous avoir répondu
sur les budgets je vous l'ai dit je veux
dire
plus d'excédent du fonds de roulement
donc on devra l'envisager je n'ose
envisager la situation n'auront pas les
moyens de travailler
j'ose espérer quand même que l'ensemble
des pouvoirs publics
tiendra compte d'une situation qui n'est
pas une situation excessive parce que
les je ne vois pas où sont les marges
les marges c'est pas dégrader la qualité
ce serait de faire des choix sur des
avis alors qu'un ensemble de missions
que vous avez confié à la SAS donc il y
a un moment je vois pas comment ce
serait réalisable donc je ne veux pas
joli très clairement l'envisager
quelques manières que ce soit
sur les la prévention en santé c'est
Madame Josso qui m'a posé la question
c'est effectivement un sujet qui est un
sujet pour la prévention santé c'est un
sujet majeur et qui couplet avec la
pertinence des questions d'acte et de et
de prise en charge
je n'ai pas vérifié mais je ne doute pas
que la chaise a déjà travaillé sur les
questions de prévention puisqu'elle a
travaillé aussi sur les questions de
pertinence mais c'est effectivement des
sujets mais ce n'est pas que la chaise
que peut apporter la chasse c'est
d'évaluer la qualité d'action de
prévention
leur retombée parce qu'on pourrait même
avoir une évaluation médico-économique
mais ensuite la décision n'est pas la
chaise vous le savez parfaitement on
fait éclairer des décisions publiques
mais c'est un sujet
indiscutable oui il y a la question du
dépistage que l'on peut effectivement
aborder
sur le
maillage territorial la chaise
n'intervient pas sur ces questions là et
qui sont des questions d'importance mais
qui sont des questions qu'on doit poser
plutôt ministre me semble-t-il à ceux
qui ont la politique en main on n'est
pas on n'est pas sur la qualité et vous
m'avez posé une question sur la
permanence des soins
et que j'entends vraiment pleinement je
veux dire cette question certains mais
ce n’est pas une question qui rentre
dans les attributions de la chasse c'est
ça je ne peux malheureusement pas aller
au-delà
écoutez moi j'ai l'impression alors si
l'histoire des délais l'histoire des
délais j'ai répondu sur le plan des
délais
et d'ailleurs je sais que madame
leguidec vous en ai déjà parlé c'est de
dire oui mais faut pas se tromper
6 2016 les industriels me disent c'est
trop long la HS aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
du tout ce retour des industriels ce
qu'ils disent c'est trop long que le
médicament arrive au prix qu'il souhaite
mais il ne me disent pas que c'est la
part de l'achat et ils disent que c'est
plutôt bien la chaise c'est vraiment
amélioré raccourci considérablement mais
je ne veux pas faire porter le chapeau à
d'autres mais il y a d'autres étapes où
il y a effectivement du délai ne
serait-ce que le délai de négociation
des prix ensuite qui prend beaucoup de
temps donc ça c'est une réalité mais je
crois que la HS peut faire mieux mais à
véritablement considérablement amélioré
ses capacités je veux dire sur le plan
de traitement des délais dans le respect
de la qualité
je vous demande juste je vous prie de
m'excuser mais là vous m'avez posé
tellement de questions que je voudrais
pas rouler les questions
fondamentalement il me semble que j'ai à
peu près répondu à l'ensemble son impact
des recommandations je l'ai expliqué par
société savante et pas et par d'autres
je crois avoir répondu madame madame la
Présidente sista satisfait mesdames et
messieurs les députés
très bien écoutez je ne vois pas de
réaction c'est que vous avez
effectivement répondu à l'ensemble des
questions en tous les cas merci vraiment
pour toutes ces réponses de qualité et
qui n'auront pas manqué d'éclairer
effectivement la représentation
nationale donc nous allons prendre congé
de vous puisque ensuite nous allons
passer au vote et encore une fois je
vous remercie monsieur Colette très bien